[Applause]
victims of a fire that killed dozens of
people at a church in giza have been
laid to rest
the community left shocked by the
seemingly senseless deaths
and lost so great it is for some
incomprehensible
my son has lost his life my son is dead
[Applause]
as the church hall fills with bodies to
be viewed mourned and prayed over
the children who died are easy to spot
the smaller the coffin the younger the
victim
grief turns quickly into anger
my children were stunning they were
angels
i know it is god's decision and i accept
it
the only question is why this happened
a faulty air conditioning unit sparked
the electrical fire five thousand
worshipers had gathered for sunday mass
people died from smoke inhalation and in
the ensuing stampede
the fourth floor of the church was on
fire there were children in the nursery
and there was a mass i don't know what
happened but there were kids and elderly
people we saved those we could we looked
up and saw a lot of black smoke and
fumes in the air
coptic christians make up about 10
percent of egypt's population and are
often the victims of discrimination
attacks and hate crimes
for many the government offers of
compensation
are unlikely to mean much in the
immediate aftermath of a tragedy that
has shaken the largest religious
minority in egypt
zing bisravi al jazeera